>>> AND THEN A FLASHBACK TO ONE
YEAR AGO TODAY.
THINK ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED ONE
YEAR AGO TODAY AND HOW IT
FORESHADOWED TODAY'S MEDIA
DIVIDE.
>>> FIRST, THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A SLOGAN AND A STORY.
RIGHT NOW IT'S IN VOGUE TO SAY
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE A MESSAGING
PROBLEM.
MAYBE THEY DO, PROBABLY DO, BUT
THAT'S FOR CANDIDATES AND
STRATEGISTS TO FIGURE OUT.
THAT'S NOT THE MEDIA'S PROBLEM.
THE MEDIA SUFFERS FROM A
DIFFERENT DILEMMA, THE SLOGAN
VERSUS THE STORY.
SLOGANS ARE SIMPLE, THEY ARE
SEDUCTIVE.
INFRASTRUCTURE WEEK IS A SLOGAN,
CHEERKY ONE.
IT BECAME A PUNCH LINE FOR YEARS
AND YEARS.
BUT IT'S JUST A SLOGAN.
THE STORY ABOUT WHAT ALL OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE MONEY, WHAT ALL
OF THE FUNDING WILL DO, THE
STORY ABOUT REBUILDING THESE
ROADS AND BRIDGES AND OF THE
EXPANSION OF BROADBAND,
INFRASTRUCTURE WEEK IS JUST A
SLOGAN.
WE NEED TO KNOW ABOUT THE STORY.
THERE'S A GOP SLOGAN OUT THERE
AS WELL, THE BILL IS A
MONSTROSITY.
THIS IS A SLOGAN REPUBLICANS ARE
USING TO ATTACK DEMOCRATS.
BUT THE STORY IS THE LAST
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT PROMISED TO
PASS AN INFRASTRUCTURE BILL AND
FAILED, SO NOW THEY NEED THE
DEMOCRATS TO FAIL TOO.
STORIES ARE COMPLEX.
STORIES HAVE HISTORICAL CONTEXT.
SLOGANS ERASE ALL OF THAT.
PARENTS' RIGHTS IS A SLOGAN.
YOU KNOW, IT'S THIS CATCHALL
TERM, WE HEARD IT CONSTANTLY
EVER SINCE THE RESULT OF THE
ELECTION IN VIRGINIA.
BUT WHICH PARENT?
WHOSE RIGHTS ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT?
HERE'S ANOTHER SLOGAN, CRITICAL
RACE THEORY HAS BECOME A SLOGAN,
AN ACTUAL INTERESTING AND
ACADEMIC TERM HAS BECOME A
SLOGAN, IT HAS BECOME A CATCHALL
PHRASE USED TO DEMONIZE, TO
WEAPONIZE.
AND, OF COURSE, ACTIVISTS WHO
TRIED TO MAKE CRITICAL RACE
THEORY INTO A NATIONAL STORY,
INTO A NATIONAL SLOGAN, THEY
KNEW WHAT THEY WERE DOING.
THEY WERE TRYING TO CREATE A
BOOGIEMAN, AND IT WORKED.
STORIES MAKE YOU THINK.
SLOGANS MAKE YOU STOP THINKING.
IF I CAN TEACH A MEDIA LITERACY
LESSON IN THE WAKE OF THE
ELECTIONS THIS WEEK, IT WILL BE
ABOUT TRYING TO TUNE OUT THE
SLOGANS AND GET TO THE REAL
STORY.
THE REAL STORIES ARE OFTEN
COMPLEX AND MESSY AND
COMPLICATED.
THAT'S WHAT MAKES THEM
INTERESTING.
SLOGANS, WE CAN DO WITH LESS OF
THOSE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE LAST WEEK
OF COVERAGE AND WHAT'S COMING UP
THIS WEEK, THAT COAX ATKINSON,
THAT NASHIA AILED FRED AND
SENIOR CORRESPONDENT AT THE GRIO
AND CNN SENIOR POLITICAL
ANALYST.
NATASHA, LET'S START WHERE YOU
ANALYZE WHAT'S HAPPENING THE
PAST FEW DAYS HERE, THE
AFTERMATH OF THE ELECTION AND
WHERE THE ARE DEMOCRATS MOVING
FORWARD?
THE DEMOCRATS DO PROBABLY HAVE A
MESSAGING PROBLEM, OKAY.
BUT WHAT'S THE MEDIA'S PROBLEM?
IT'S A DIFFERENT ISSUE THAN THE
DEMOCRATS MAY OR MAY NOT HAVE.
>> I THINK THE MEDIA HAS A
PROBLEM OF TRYING TO ANSWER BIG
QUESTIONS BY OUR DEADLINE.
>> INTERESTING, OKAY.
>> VERSUS HOW LIFE ACTUALLY
PLAYS OUT.
I THINK WE ALSO HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH TAKING SLOGANS THAT WERE
DESIGNED BY POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS
AND PARTIES WITH AN AGENDA AND
BEING UNINTENTIONAL CARRIERS OF
THEIR AGENDA, RIGHT.
>> GIVE ME AN EXAMPLE.
>> WHAT IS PARENTS' RIGHTS?
I SAW THIS GREAT TWEET BY JEMELE
HILL WHERE CBS ASKED, WHEN IS
TOO EARLY TO TALK ABOUT RACE?
AND JEMELE ASKED ALL OF HER
FOLLOWERS, WELL, WHEN WAS THE
FIRST TIME YOU DEALT WITH
RACISM?
AND THERE WERE THOUSANDS OF
TWEETED, MANY FROM BLACK PEOPLE
SAYING WHEN I WAS 4, WHEN I WAS
5.
>>> SO THE FRAMING IS OFF HERE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WHEN IS TOO
EARLY WHEN FOR AN ENTIRE
DEMOGRAPHIC, THIS IS REALITY
FROM THE DAY WE'RE BORN.
SO WHO ARE WE TALKING ABOUT
EXACTLY?
I THINK THE LARGER POINT IS WE
FALL INTO THIS TRAP, WE'RE
MANIPULATED AND WE REPEAT THE
PHRASES TRYING TO ANSWER THE
CRITICS PUT OUT THERE TO BERATE
THE PUBLIC DIALOGUE.
>> NICOLE, HOW DO YOU SEE THAT?
>> I AGREE WITH THAT AND THERE'S
ALSO A FAILURE TO REFORM.
THERE WAS A POLL THAT CAME BACK
THAT 50% OF THE PEOPLE HAD NO
IDEA WHAT IS IN THE BUILD BACK
BETTER BILL.
SOME OF THAT IS ON CONSUMERS AND
MEDIA BUT IT DOES SUGGEST
THERE'S SO MUCH SPOKEN ENERGY,
SO MUCH TALK ABOUT HORSE RACE
POLITICS, SO MUCH OF A SPOTLIGHT
ON PEOPLE LIKE JOE MANCHIN AND
KRYSTEN SINEMA BUT NOT ENOUGH
ATTENTION TO INFORM PEOPLE WHAT
IS ACTUALLY IN THE LEGISLATION.
>> ISN'T THAT THE DEMOCRATS'
FAULT?
SHOULDN'T THE DEMOCRATS COMPLAIN
WHAT'S IN THE SFWHIL.
>> DEMOCRATS SHOULD EXPLAIN THE
BILL BUT JOURNALISTS ALSO HAVE A
ROLE EXPLAINING WHAT'S IN THE
BILL ABOUT TO BE PASSED.
THE BIG PROBLEM WITH THE
DEMOCRATS IS NOT WHAT'S IN THE
BIG BUT TELLING A STORY ABOUT
WHAT'S IN THE BILL.
CONNECTING EMOTIONALLY WITH
PEOPLE ABOUT WHAT'S IN THE DOOR.
IT SEEMS LIKE JOURNALISTS HAVE A
ROLE ON THE INFORMATIONAL SIDE
OF THINGS.
>> CLAIRE, THIS HAS TO DO WITH
FORMS OF MEDIA, TELEVISION NEWS
VERSUS DEEP DIVES ON DIGITAL
THAT ARE BEHIND SUBSCRIBER PAY
WALLS.
SOMETIMES IF YOU'RE GETTING FREE
OR CHEAP NEWS ON THE WEB, YOU'RE
NOT GETTING THE SUBSTANCE.
YOU'RE NOT GETTING THE IN DEPTH
REPORTING.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
I THINK ALL POLITICS IS
MARKETING AND THERE'S A REASON
FOR THAT.
IT'S ABOUT APPEALING TO A
BROADER RANGE OF PEOPLE AS YOU
CAN.
TV NEWS IS ABOUT EXPLAINING VERY
COMPLICATED TOPICS IN VERY SHORT
SEGMENTS.
THAT IN AND OF ITSELF CREATES
PROBLEMS IN THAT YOU CAN'T
EXPLAIN THINGS BECAUSE THE
VIEWERS ARE GOING TO GO OFF AND
RATINGS GO DOWN IF YOU GET INTO
THE WEED OF THINGS.
WE'VE SEEN FOX NEWS BE ABLE TO
APPROPRIATE COMPLEX ISSUES,
PORTRAY THEM IN VERY
BLACK-AND-WHITE TERMS AND CREATE
VERY COMPELLING TELEVISION,
WHERE IT'S ABOUT CRT OR PARENTS'
BILL OF RIGHTS OR FIGHTS BETWEEN
SCHOOL BOARDS AND GROUPS OF
PARENTS ON THESE GROUPS OF
ISSUES.
I THINK IT'S FAIR FOR THE NEWS
MEDIA TO KIND OF LOOK INTO WHAT
IS HAPPENING IN SCHOOLS AND WHAT
DOES CRT MEAN, AND WHAT ARE KIDS
BEING TAUGHT IN SCHOOLS?
AND I DON'T THINK IT'S JUST FOX
NEWS LOOKING AT THAT ISSUE.
IT'S BARRY WHITE, THE FORMER
"NEW YORK TIMES" CORRESPONDENT,
FORMER NEW YORK MAG
CORRESPONDENT ANDREW SULLIVAN
WHO ARE ALSO ASKING THE
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT IS FAIR
WHEN IT COMES TO ACCUSATIONS OF
RACISM AND HOW CRT IS BIDEN
INSTILLED.
>> LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT THIS AND
TELL ME IF YOU AGREE.
IT SEEMS LIKE AN OBVIOUS ISSUE
AND EVERY PARENT KNOWS IT ABOUT
SCHOOL AND THEY ARE THE
PANDEMIC.
REAL ISSUES ABOUT LEARNING LOSS,
REAL ISSUES ABOUT SCHOOL BOARDS
IN PARTICULAR.
BUT THERE'S ALSO AN APOCALYPTIC
NARRATIVE THAT COMES FROM RIDE
WING MEDIA, INCLUDING FOX, THAT
IS OUT OF PROPORTION AND SEEMS
EXAGGERATED.
IT SEEMS TO ME, NATASHA, THAT
BOTH ARE TRUE BUT IT'S
REDEFINED.
CRT IS A REAL THING, ACADEMIC
STUDYING FOR A LIVING BUT NOW
THE PHRASE HAS COME TO MEAN
SOMETHING DIFFERENT IN OUR
POLITICAL ATMOSPHERE.
>> YES, AND WHAT'S INTERESTING
IS SO MANY OF THESE DEBATES ARE
OLD.
>> OH?
>> THEY'RE JUST REHASHED.
WHEN I WAS A LOCAL NEWS
REPORTER, SOME OF THE MOST
INTENSE STORIES WERE SCHOOL
BOARD MEETINGS AND THEY WERE
ABOUT BUSING KIDS FROM THE CITY
INTO THE SUBURBS.
THESE ARE AMERICA'S ISSUES WITH
RACE AND IDENTITY AND THE SORT
OF THIS MORAL OUTRAGE THAT JUST
GETS REPACKAGED FOR A NEW ERA.
>> WHEN THE TOP ISSUE WAS CALLED
EDUCATION, THE TOP ISSUE IS
RACE.
>> IT IS RACE AND IT'S OUR JOB
TO PROVIDE HISTORICAL CONTEXT SO
READERS JUST DON'T TAKE THAT
HEADLINE AND SAY PARENTS RIGHTS
AND THEN IT BECOMES THE DEBATES
ABOUT WHAT THE PEOPLE VERSUS THE
AGENDA THAT WANT US TO DEBATE,
THE LARGER PICTURE THAT WE
SHOULD BE AWARE OF AND ALSO KNOW
ABOUT.
>> IT SEEMS LIKE A LOT OF
FRUSTRATION, DISCONTENT AMONG
DEMOCRATS WITH THE MEDIA RIGHT
NOW.
I SEE SENATOR BRIAN SCHATZ ON
TWITTER SAYING THE MEDIA NEEDS
TO CATCH UP TO THE STORY OF THE
ECONOMY.
THE ECONOMY IS REALLY STEAMLING
BACK.
I SEE A LOT OF CRITICISM FROM
THE RANK AND FILE OF THE PRESS
SAY THE PRESS IS NOT
UNDERSTANDING THE SERIOUSNESS OF
THE BILL, IT'S NOT CELEBRATING
BIDEN'S WINS -- IT'S NOT OUR JOB
TO CELEBRATE BUT WE DO NEED TO
PROVIDE THE PROPER CONTEXT OF
WHAT'S HAPPENING.
HOW DO YOU VIEW OUR ECONOMY NOW?
>> I THINK WE FORGET PEOPLE
EXPERIENCED THE ECONOMY, NOT
JUST THROUGH THE MEDIA, BUT
THEIR OWN EXPERIENCE.
WE'RE ABSOLUTELY NOT HERE TO BE
PROMOTERS OF THE BIDEN AGENDA IN
ANY WAY.
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE QUESTIONING
IT.
SO THAT'S THE FIRST ROLE OF
JOURNALISM.
AS YOU SAID, CONTEXT IS
EVERYTHING.
THERE ARE SOME WINS.
BUT PEOPLE GO OUT, AND THEY
LISTEN TO HEADLINES ABOUT
INFLATION, THEY SEE SUPPLY-CHAIN
ISSUES BEING BROUGHT UP TIME AND
TIME AGAIN.
THEY